[Applause]
wow thank you so
much I don't think I've ever met anyone
with such an interesting career like you
like you're you're in boxing for like 15
years right correct yeah first of all
welcome to the show honor to have you
here um but also then like what like how
did this start how did you go how did
you start boxing why was that a thing
for you well you know I'm one of five
children and I have two older brothers I
know we were talking about siblings
earlier and um I've always been really
sporty as a kid basketball softball my
mom was really girly she wanted me to
wear dresses and I'm like in trees and I
just wanted to fight the boys in the
neighborhood but boxing wasn't something
that nobody did in my family or anything
and I just really like the solo aspect
of boxing it kind of found me and um I
needed somewhat of an outlet um going
through some things as a kid and then I
got my butt whooped my first fight my
first amateur fight and it was one of
those things do I say this isn't for me
or I wanted to see how does that not
happen again so I just honed in on it
and wanted to just become the best I
could yeah you're badass thank you yeah
you how how did it go from boxing to
acting like what did you always kind of
have a dream for that like secretly you
know I've been asking myself this
question a lot like how did this happen
I really don't know it just kind of
happened I mean those are the best
things though that you don't it just
organically happens in life yeah I mean
I'm really artistic um you know I played
the violin when I was 9 years old come
from a musically inclined family and I
was like something that I I wasn't like
I want to grow up and I want to be in
Hollywood I was like that'd be kind of
cool I want to kind of try it one day
but I did have this like thing I used to
do with my mom when she come home I'd
like play around with like her like
dresses and stuff like that and come
with the up with these characters yeah
and like I had these specific characters
I was just entertain my family all the
time but I'm like you know maybe one day
it will find me if it's meant for me
it'll find me and then it found me it
found me I know it found you and you're
incredible at both things like you it's
such a it's just a random career right
and like not many people have that's
such a blessing I think it's cool to
stand out in that way AB absolutely yeah
your mom gave you a nickname right so my
Native American name is mcquin OG which
means many feathers many talents and um
she uh I guess she kind of saw what I
was going to do yeah I was going to say
wow no stradamus I was like saw that
coming yeah so it's actually quite an
honor CU um she saw a lot of things in
me I didn't see in myself um as as a kid
and it took a while for me to kind of
get comfortable where I am now so I
embraced that name and just I stick to
it making sure I get the best out of
myself no matter what it is you know and
I have many many talents to and many
gifts too to share with the world and
who knows what else as well I don't know
yeah I don't know how did this role like
how did it find you how did you find it
how did you land in the show so catch
the faren was my first ever time acting
and I actually helped write the film and
they were looking for somebody to fill
the the role of Navaro and Issa Lopez
and her casting director got a hold of
catch the fair one she just wanted to
basically kind of know how I started um
what my process was um she also Issa
involves um murdered women in her a lot
of hard work because she's from Mexico
Mexico City so there's a lot of that
epidemic going around so we kind of
collaborated and just had a conversation
on what we did with catch the phin and
what she does in her work yeah and I
auditioned for it and it was another
thing where I was like if it's meant for
me it it'll it'll happen I actually
wrote funny story I wrote I will get the
part of evangelene Naro and True
Detective night country over and over in
my notebook and then I got the call
projected yes man yes man exactly yes
abolutely oh my god well how how is
being on the show helped you highlight
what's happening with indigenous women
because I had no idea until I saw this
movie I can't remember the name but
Jeremy rener was in it and um Wind River
Wind River I I had no idea and it broke
my heart at the end of the movie they
put like this really is happening and
and I was like wait what and it's such a
a lot of people don't know they're just
disappearing these women are
disappearing like how do you feel like
your success is obviously had an impact
on the community right I would like to
think so I mean with my boxing career I
would did my best to just bring
awareness to missing ured indigenous
people or mmiw um it's one of those
things that help highlight exactly
what's happening in indigenous
communities it's not just our women it's
our our men our women our boys our
elders and our people are getting
targeted so was one it's one of those
things even with these these earrings
with the red handprint anytime you see
these red handprints on anything it's
basically uh you'll see a red handprint
over um their mouths just saying there
silencing our voices so with my boxing
career I had an audience that didn't
know just like you didn't about it so I
would just speak about it in front of
audience that don't know about it to
spread the word to spread awareness to
stop this violence against women so to
be involved in any kind of projects or
anything to be able to talk talk about
it yeah you know we're just taught to
fight for those who can't fight speak
for those who you have to talk about it
people didn't even no like I was Sting
and I felt like foolish and I was
ashamed I was watching it and I was like
wait what I had no idea you know it
happens it doesn't happen art is for
right exactly it's not just one area
it's not just one PE one area of America
it's in Canada it's an any indigenous
people in anywhere in the world you'll
see that we're we're targeted as a
people but especially here in in North
America and it happens right next door
yeah so I'm glad you're using your
Spotlight for that that's it's important
well everybody be sure to check out True
Detective night country on
[Music]
[Applause]
Max thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home